what should you do if the police stop
you on the street in the US stay calm
and don't argue keep your hands where
police can see them you have the right
to remain silent
say it out loud ask if you are being
detained if not you are free to leave if
so you have the right to find out why
you have the right to refuse consent to
a search of your car your home or
yourself unless the police have a search
warrant or suspect that your car
contains evidence of a crime but police
can Pat you down for weapons without a
warrant police cannot search your phone
or confiscate footage and you do have
the right to film police in public if
you are arrested you have the right to
know why and the right to a lawyer even
a free one check out your local ACLU for
more info